do you want to invest your savings in
insurance or investment products here's
the kind of information you'll receive
from your bank
a brochure that's dozens of pages long
difficult to compare and often opaque
financial products are in the hot seat
the european parliament wants key
information documents to accompany these
kind of products to facilitate
understanding and comparison
but members of the european parliament
are having a hard time agreeing on which
financial products to cover
we are friends but i don't like that you
you're not going to support me on the
scope because i think we had good
exchange but in this case i thought i've
always been a view that we should have
had a step-by-step approach start with
the scope roughly is envisaged by the
commission
prove it works consumer test it and then
in future years look to extend the scope
to other products such as you know
shares and bonds and some of the other
products that were talked about here
let's start off with a more more complex
financial products prove that the
document's useful and then in future
years extend it to other financial
products the vision isn't shared by the
dossiers
euro mps won't settle the dossier before
november